you know like so many people before me I
found it impossible to not be in
absolute awe of Michael and his
overwhelming strength his passion and
his relentless commitment to help those
impacted by Parkinson's disease
this guy is inspiration exemplified and
a ton of things changed from that first
meeting in a terrible lapse of judgment
I signed up to run in the New York City
Marathon I became part of Team Fox which
is just inspires me daily many people
don't know this that I'm the only person
in the history of New York City Marathon
to cross the finish line
legally dead so that's me
I was incredibly inspired my nipples are
fine sir thank you very much
I hope you're having a wonderful weekend
I was incredibly inspired by the
Foundation's progress and I I then
joined the Board of Directors and that
progress is incredible when I joined the
board it was 2008 and the foundation had
funded over 150 million dollars in
research programs today we're on the
precipice of 1 billion dollars yeah back
then we hadn't launched win yet launched
the Foundation's game-changing landmark
Parkinson's progression markers
initiative and today it's active in 33
global sites and has enrolled 1500
participants researchers around the
world have downloaded data from the
study 5 million times and we're on the
verge of relaunching and expanding it
genetic understanding of Parkinson's was
limited in 2008 and today that we have
we have three major genetic targets with
close to 20 treatment tested in human
trials and when I first joined the board
way back when we had about 33,000
individual donors and today we have
nearly 100,000 donors a year a year
I consider myself incredibly lucky to be
one of the millions who is committed as
ever to doing whatever I can to support
the Foundation's mission and it's really
really not that hard when Michael and
Tracy are involved their optimism is
contagious and it fuels our resolve
until we find a cure I know every single
person in this room looks up to Michael
and Tracy for inspiration on the days
when the struggle is real and I mean I
can only really speak for myself but I
don't I look up to them spiritually but
you know they're very small people so
you know I look down at them at about a
45 ish sort of a bit of a rakish kind of
you know and I'm 5-1 you know they're
like 3/4 inches everyone in this room is
is part of the Foundation's family and
history and every milestone reached is a
testament to the perseverance of our
community to speed a cure for
Parkinson's disease